- You're just happy?
- [Staphon] I knew you (mumbling).
- [Steve] Andy's happy.
- [Steve] Andy's in a good mood today.
(all chattering)
- [Gary] You're in a good mood today?
A lot of good things are happening?
- [Andy] Yeah,
man, getting shit done,
making it happen.
- Seriously? That's why
you're in a good mood?
- [Andy] Yes.
- That's nice.
- [Andy] And I won
my last game, but.
- Did you see that I,
like, basically played with one arm?
- Yeah, you're, yeah,
you literally had one arm.
- I literally played,
I really hurt myself lifting.
Right now I'm on aspirin.
I don't take medicine,
so anything like, ever, so I feel OK.
- [Andy] Is it like right here?
- Yeah, it's right here.
- That happened to me.
I thought I was like, (mumbling).
- [Voiceover] Does it hurt
there when you touch it?
- It feels better.
- [Andy] Pulled muscles.
- But then you were fine, from lifting?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- And then you were fine next day?
- [Andy] In like two days.
- Yeah, I think that's,
I'm hoping that's the case, all right.
- [Voiceover] Gary, I
got a question for you.
Why are so many people--
- I don't need to see
him. I'm just gonna go.
- [Steve] OK.
- Ready?
- [Steve] You're just gonna go?
- Yup. 110?
- [DRock] And action.
(rap music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- On this episode, we talk at why
people are scared about SnapChat,
we talk ego,
and I talk to my future grandchildren.
(group laughing)
Hey, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 110
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm in a very, very good mood
because Andy's in a good mood.
He just came in and he's
in a very good mood.
Holy crap, did you get
your head bumped into?
- Yeah, Taggart crushed me.
- Like, zone in here.
This is from basketball this morning.
(all laughing)
This is amazing.
Was that on the last
play that ended the game?
- Yeah, it was the game point.
You won the game on that play.
I'm impressed with you.
I like Andy.
AJ got married this weekend.
It was tremendous.
That was massively enjoyable,
one of the best weekends
of my entire life.
I'm in good spirits.
There's a ton of good stuff
going on with business.
I'm extremely fired up
for the #AskGaryVee Show
and the podcast, you've been noticing,
if you're paying attention,
over the last two or three days,
I've been really pushing the podcast.
I've decided that I wanna
shoot up the rankings
on the iTunes score.
Number 14 today? 13 in
the business section.
I wanna be number one.
But Ferriss is gonna own that.
He's, like, all in,
and the video siphons,
I noticed in a lot of the comments,
people are going to the
video, because I get it,
super attractive, very
charismatic on video.
(all laughing)
I get that, but
really wanna give a huge shoutout
to everybody who's listening right now
in a commute and, more importantly,
VaynerNation, serious right hook alert.
DRock, do something,
"right hook alert," like, make something
so I can start doing that more often.
(dramatic music)
Vayner Nation,
serious right hook alert.
Even if you're not gonna listen to it,
I'll take the download,
'cause I'm hacking.
I wanna shoot up the ranks,
'cause the discovery for people seeing me
who don't know who I am, which is,
believe it or not, 99% of the world,
there's an opportunity there,
and so I'm enjoying that.
I'm also very seriously considering
answering a unique question
every single episode
exclusively to the podcast first.
It'd be good because, for the people,
then they don't have to listen
through the whole thing,
so maybe we do it first,
maybe I start the show
with like, "Here's the,"
maybe even before the intro, DRock,
I'm like, "Here's the exclusive answer."
This way, for the people
that are really hardcore
that wanna hear every goddamn answer,
they can just listen to
that part on the podcast
and then move on with their merry way
if they're video watching.
So a little hacking going on on my end.
My Instagram game is up, 110,000,
106,000 followers right now?
Serious. Excited about that.
And just really fired up about the show.
Really enjoying the process.
You guys know I love the journey.
So many new fans popping
up because of this show,
and that's super humbling
and I appreciate it,
so big shoutout.
Leave in the comments
on YouTube and Facebook
if you are somebody who
just discovered my content
in the last six months or less.
I'd like to triple down on my thank yous
and appreciation,
and all you OGs, you know
how much love I have for you,
but I'd love to give a little (clapping)
emoji high-five to some new peeps.
Stunwin,
let's get into
the show!
India on vacation.
This is old school.
It's a throwback Mon, Tuesday,
with Steve asking the questions. Let's go!
- [Voiceover] Chad asks,
"At what point in time,
"if at all, should a brand
not use social media?"
- Steve.
- [Steve] Chad.
- Chad.
(all laughing)
Chad, great question.
You know, the funny thing is,
is all that social media is is another,
first of all, social media is a term,
a slang term for the current state
of the Internet right now.
The term we used only
six or seven years ago
was "web 2.0 sites."
Now we call them "social media sites."
We may call them something
else in the future,
"mobile native," "virtual this,"
but there's always a term to talk about
the 20 to 30 sites that matter.
Social media sites
happen to mean the sites
that people actually go to,
the apps that people actually go to
in a mobile first world,
which is what we live in now,
and so people are confused
if there's something,
if there is a thing called social media.
There isn't.
I mean, anything that's
a content site now,
anything that, like, people refer to
podcasts as social media.
It's just a term of relevancy,
and so it's a communication portal, right?
And there are some high,
high, high end brands
that think if they're on Twitter
or Snapchat or Instagram or Facebook
that they cheapen their brand equity.
I would say Apple, right?
Apple is a brand that does very little.
I still think they're doing
basically nothing on social,
or at least, definitely not on Twitter,
I don't think, right?
So, you know, look, do I think
that there is a place where
brands should not do it?
Only if it's a shtick.
If it's a very well-thought-out,
"we are so exclusive, we're
going against the grain,"
and they make it part
of their overall thing,
that they emphasize in other
channels of communication
their lack of being there.
It may position to a small group
that is anti-establishment,
that they think that's cool,
but more and more, what
people need to recognize
is that social media is going through
a legitimacy curve right now.
Over the next five to ten years,
this will be the establishment.
Facebook and Twitter and Pin,
well, I don't know about
Twitter, I'm worried,
but Facebook and Instagram and Snapchat,
they're gonna be the establishment.
It's like banner ads
or the Internet itself.
It's just gonna be the
establishment, my friends,
and so I think eventually,
that's going to run out.
If you wanna sell something,
you need to be able
to communicate to the world,
and if everybody's eyes and ears
are in a certain place
called the Internet,
I think you need to be there,
and I think you have a tough argument
to justify the upside versus the downside
of not communicating in the portals
where people are living.
Ben. Oh, I know Ben Phillips.
- Hey, Gary. I got a question for you.
Why are so many people scared of Snapchat,
especially in the marketing field?
A lot of them say they
don't understand it,
but I feel like that's a copout.
What do you think?
- Ben, I think it's ironic that you wore
a yellow shirt when you
asked that question.
I wonder if that was strategic.
If it was, a big daps to you.
Also enjoying the beard
and the glasses look.
You look really legit.
I think that people are not practitioners.
I would argue that 95%
of people in marketing,
95% of people in marketing,
at digital and social
agencies on the brands
and the business sides
actually don't know how Snapchat works,
actually have never went through
all four screens of Snapchat.
To the left, to the right
twice and the camera itself.
Literally have not done that. Literally.
I would argue that 70% of marketers
have never touched one of
the Discover tabs on Snapchat
because they are just not practitioners,
and Snapchat has a context
and a cadence and a system
that is not native to a lot of people
because it's left to
right, not up and down
like all the other apps,
and so there's some learning.
Like, it actually takes
four to five minutes
of thought and energy
to really understand
how Snapchat works
if you've never used it before,
and that's about four
to five minutes' worth
of actual practitionership
that most people don't apply.
They like to headline read that the kids
send sex pictures to each other
and they like to be old white men
even if they're not old white men. Right?
Plenty of 23-year-old Hispanic women
acting like old white men 'cause
they're not practitioners.
Slang term "old white men,"
to like "you suck shit."
Like you're not putting in the work,
you're tired, you're not innovating,
you stink.
You stink, you stink.
And so why do I think people
are scared of Snapchat?
Because they stink.
Because most people suck at marketing.
Most people just wanna do
what they've already known.
They don't evolve.
I wake up every morning of my life
trying to put myself out of business,
because it's a lot better to do that
than have somebody else do it for me,
and that's how I live, and
that's how I'm gonna live
until I'm an old white man
acting like a 14-year-old chick, right?
'Cause that's just the way I'm gonna roll.
And so as you can see,
I got a little excited
on this answer,
because it strikes a real nerve to
what's actually happening in society,
because as we are living through
the second Industrial Revolution,
the real culture shift
of the last half century,
this Internet thing, getting to maturity
with mobile devices at scale,
computing on our fingertips
at all times at scale,
the whole kit and kaboodle.
Society, the whole thing, everyone,
all of us, everyone.
When that hits, and that's here,
and it's starting to really hit,
everything changes forever.
Everything. Everything.
Marketing just happens to be the part
that I'm most interested in talking about.
- [Andy] Hot damn.
Episode 110: "Old White Guys Suck."
- [Voiceover] Mike wants to know,
"Are you building an
eco-system or an ego-system?"
- Michael, this is a
great, great question,
and I think the answer is both.
I think the true answer is both.
I think that I've
created an infrastructure
of free content and interaction
and organization
that has created an ecosystem.
It's super hard to argue.
I mean, wait 'til "Crushed It" comes out,
the book that follows the 400 people,
which is 400 of the 4,000 people
that read "Crush It"
and their lives changed.
Go read the comments in the Facebook posts
and in the Instagram
posts around this show
of people literally, in the last 30 days,
'cause I'm reading them all,
just talking about how, like, weird,
watching 100 episodes of
this has changed their life.
They make more money,
like, real life stuff.
So that's an ecosystem.
On the flip side, it's very centraled
around a human being, right? Me.
And that's an ego-system,
so I think the answer is both,
and I think that, you know,
I think like anything in life,
there's a very fine line.
I often use Oprah to
bunch of spammy gurus.
She just walked the fine line
of inspiration and motivation just right
to create all-time great billionaireship
and all-time great impact,
whereas, gosh, if she just turned an inch
in the other direction, and if you look
at her early career, she
probably was in that lane,
and I think when she was able to squeak it
a little bit more to the left,
it took her to the stratosphere.
Look, I think I'm
walking a very fine line,
and I think I'm walking it properly,
and I think I believe that
because I just clearly know myself best
and know my motivations,
and I think that if you were to intimately
look under the hood of
my actions and career,
you would see all the dollars
I'm leaving on the table,
which I think usually tend to be
the motivator that forces people
to get on the wrong side of the road
of this eco-ego system
that you talk about.
And so I think the answer is both.
I very much thrive off the attention,
the pressure,
the admiration,
the trolling and hating.
It's all part of it,
and I think I'm capable and
I have broad enough shoulders
and puffy enough chests to be able
to deal with it, and so
the answer is both,
and I think done right, done properly,
by all standards of the seven-person jury,
I think it's the way to
pull off a great legacy,
and that's what I'm trying to do.
What do you think, Steve?
- [Steve] I agree.
- [Gary] Seriously?
- Yeah.
- All right, thanks.
- [Voiceover] Andrew wants to know,
"Do you see skill sharing
and teaching people skills
"as an alternative to education
"coming up in the sharing economy?"
- Andrew, I do.
Very simply, the answer is yes.
Very simply, I believe the Internet
is gonna squeeze everything in the middle
that doesn't provide value out of business
over a 100-year period,
and so everything's in the middle, really,
between you and a thing,
and the education system is
in the middle between you
and actually having the
next chapter of your life
in play monetizing, if
you really think about it.
At its grand scheme, you go to school,
in theory, historically, the
way it's been thought of,
to set you up, to monetize your thing.
I mean, as we know, so many people
go through the schooling and then realize
they don't wanna be a lawyer or a doctor
or whatever they've been learning to do,
and they reset and they
go into the open market.
I think that that needs
to be thought about.
I think that really needs
to be thought about,
and we've never lived in a time where,
guys, at 30 years old, I began
the first seed of thought
that I should speak to
the world about something.
That happened to be wine at the time.
I mean, there wasn't things
like this podcast, this show,
or the billions of pieces of content
that live now, that educate people
at a level that we've never seen before.
If there is anyone, if there is anyone
that believes that
unionized human beings and old textbooks
can outperform education
of information and thinking
to the vast majority of human
society and the Internet,
then you are a lost human being.
Lost. With a capital L.
And so now what needs to happen is,
some organization.
Look, I actually believe
the following statement.
I actually believe one
of the singular reasons
that universities are in play
is the romantic point of view
that the parents of our current generation
view on the institution,
and I truly believe it's going to take
only two more generations.
Not necessarily mine, but my kids
have no prayer of valuing
Harvard and Stanford
and a community college to the level
it's valued by my parents.
No shot in hell, I'm putting it,
and I don't like to predict,
but I'm putting it right here on film.
Big ups to my little grandchildren
that are watching this
now, 50 years from now.
(all laughing)
Hey, little Sarah. I love you.
And, you know.
Actually, Sarah's gonna
be so out of date by then.
Hey, Zeruca, big fan.
Hope we're watching this together.
So I think that, you know,
the skill shares, the Khan Academies,
the endless content on YouTube,
the podcasts,
the tremendous impact that all the content
that's living right now is
having on the younger generation
and how they will think that they,
right now we have 15-year-olds
that think their two
cents on every thought
are public domain,
that they need to add their two cents.
What do you think when
they become educated
through school and not school,
what they're gonna share and how?
It's just gonna be so much information.
Plus, our system right
now is so predicated
on teaching our kids to memorize something
and then regurgitate it
a couple of weeks later,
in a world where all that information
is at their fingertips.
Nobody gives a shit who the 18th President
of the United States is,
or what's the warmest planet.
I can tell you in one
fucking second, you idiots.
(all laughing)
I mean, it's just stupid.
What are you guys looking at?
- [Voiceover] Sorry, it
was the Inc. article.
- Got it.
- [Voiceover] (mumbling),
they're linking out now.
- Got it.
(all laughing)
That's all I got.
A lot of gray there at
the end there for you.
A little black and white
action for you, DRock.
Question of the day.
I'm actually curious about
this, so answer quickly,
because I know this is
going in motion right now.
Do you think that the Warriors
hold on and win the championship,
or do you think LeBron pulls off
historic game six and
game seven victories?
I wanna see in the comments
who's gonna close out this NBA finals.
I'm curious, also, part B,
did you sign up for the podcast,
yes or no?
Put a #2 in the comment section
and say yes or no.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(laughing) Cool.
- [DRock] Podcast question?
- Yes, let's do it.
Find something.
You can just go to Twitter search.
- [Steve] Actually, how
about the fifth question
that we didn't ask during the show?
- There's a fifth question?
- [Steve] You were
running long, so I just--
- Got it.
- [Steve] Yup, all right.
Ready?
- Should we do the fifth
and just plug it in? No, that'd be,
you know what, gray
this whole thing, DRock.
Actually, don't gray it, play it anyway,
you know what I mean.
And then let's do this fifth
question for the podcast.
Ready, you're just gonna do the audio?
Cool.
(mumbling)
(rap music)